Jörg Schönenborn zu der tarifeinigungen
öffentlichen Dienst und hatte auch einen
interessante Gäste Runde dabei ich sage
einstweilen von hier an dieser Stelle
tschüss und Ihnen einen schönen Sonntag
bei Phoenix
erinnerungsanträge mehr
jetzt live aus Köln der Presseclub mit
Jörg Schönenborn herzlich willkommen
schön dass Sie dabei sind an diesem
Sonntagmittag beim Presseclub der für
uns alle mit einer richtig guten
Nachricht beginnt denn größere Streiks
im öffentlichen Dienst sind abgewendet
auch die Warnstreiks in Kitas
Krankenhäusern und anderen kommunalen
Einrichtungen die in den letzten Wochen
viele genervt haben gehören der
Vergangenheit an denn die Tarifpartner
haben sich in der vergangenen Nacht für
2,5 Millionen Beschäftigte bei Städten
Gemeinden Kreisen und beim Bund auf
deutlich mehr Geld geeinigt das sei sagt
eine Vertreterin der Städte der teuerste
Tarifabschluss der Geschichte allerdings
war es auch die schwierigste Tarifrunde
seit Jahrzehnten denn auf der einen
Seite frisst die Inflation die Kaufkraft
unser aller Löhne und Gehälter und auf
der anderen Seite haben weder die
öffentliche Hand noch die ersten
Unternehmen das Geld in der Kasse das
einfach auszugleichen unser Presseclub
heute der Schlichterspruch fairer
Ausgleich oder fauler Kompromiss und ich
freue mich auf diese Gäste Antje Höning
ist wieder bei uns sie leitet für die
Rheinische Post nein doch sie leitet die
Wirtschaftsredaktion der Rheinischen
Post herzlich willkommen Anja Krüger ist
Parlaments Korrespondentin für
Wirtschaft und Umwelt bei der
Tageszeitung taz ich freue mich auf
Frank Thomas Wenzel
wirtschaftskorrespondent beim
redaktionsnetzwerk Deutschland und
Alexander hagelücken ist leitender
Redakteur für Wirtschaftspolitik bei der
Süddeutschen Zeitung
wie andere am Tisch sind auch Sie jemand
der Tarifverhandlungen seit vielen
Jahren verfolgt sie haben heute morgen
über den Abschluss auf Basis eines
schlichter Spruchs schon geschrieben
Zahlen sind massig in der Welt viele
Interpretationen sagen Sie doch mal was
ist für Sie der Kern was da geschlossen
worden ist wir haben gesagt schon es ist
eine sehr schwierige Tarifrunde wir
haben eine so hohe Inflation wie seit
Jahrzehnten und das ist klar glaube
wichtig dass die Arbeitnehmer da einfach
auf sehr viel mehr Lohn gedrängt haben
auch mit Streiks das ist auch glaube ich
angemessen in der Situation gleichzeitig
ist es so dass das Geld beim Start nicht
unbedingt so super locker sitzt ich
finde man muss da unterscheiden weil es
Kommunen gibt die nicht viel Geld haben
und dass wir die Bundesregierung hat
auch durch die Inflation höhere
Steuereinnahmen das heißt man musste
dann Deal finden ich glaube es ist ein
gutes Ergebnis weil es gleichzeitig von
den doch sehr hohen Forderung von Verdi
die man teilweise auch überzogen finden
konnte 10,5% Lohn für nur ein Jahr mehr
doch ein gewissen Abstand hat also
finanzierbar ist aber gleichzeitig
bringt es den vielen Beschäftigten im
öffentlichen Dienst mehr Geld dass sie
dringend brauchen ich finde das ist eine
gute Einigung Frau Höning wie viel ist
es denn jetzt 5,5 steht auf dem Etikett
Herr Wernecke gerade in der Tagesschau
spricht von bis zu 16,9 ist ein großes
Zahlenlotto das da gerade stattfindet
genau das ist natürlich auch Interessen
getrieben was da gesagt wird also das
ist so dass ab nächsten Jahr 5,5%
gezahlt der Tarifvertrag hat ja eine
Laufzeit von zwei Jahren
und es kommen die Einmalzahlungen dazu
die auch wirksam sind also insgesamt
kann Verdi sagen 11 Prozent über zwei
Jahre aber pro Jahr umgerechnet ist es
dann rund
5,5 Prozent also weit weg von der absurd
hohen Forderung von 10,5% und deshalb
wirklich ein Ergebnis was in Ordnung ist
womit die Kommunen leben können und die
Gewerkschaft muss jetzt sehen wie sie
die hohen Erwartungen die sie bei den
Mitgliedern geweckt hat wieder einfängt
10,5% pro Jahr war einfach nicht drin
was ist für Sie so ein Kern der sie
überrascht freut ärgert an diesem
Tarifvertrag
Tarifvertrag über zwei Jahre läuft denn
ich finde dass das ein ganz bitterer
Kompromiss ist für die Beschäftigten man
muss sehen wer die hat für ein Jahr
10,5% gefordert jetzt gibt es im ersten
Jahr quasi 0 Lohnerhöhung es gibt die
inflationsausgleichsprämie aber das ist
ja keine Lohnerhöhung das ist ja gedacht
um die Inflation auszugleichen und unter
diesen Umständen finde ich das schon
sehr bitter es hat aber natürlich den
Vorteil dass die Beschäftigten gerade
die unteren Lohngruppen schnell Geld
bekommen und das ist auch wirklich nötig
ist das Pferd
ich stimme den zu dass die unteren
Lohngruppen profitieren also wenn man
auf die Tabelle guckt wir haben eben
schon mal im Vorgespräch kurz drüber
gesprochen 2000 Euro gibt es da noch
damit kann jemand der einen
Ballungsgebiet wohnt nicht leben und da
kommen jetzt 340 350 Euro drauf das
werden die Leute schon spüren aber wir
haben sozusagen das strukturelle Problem
was wir im öffentlichen Dienst haben
nämlich dass wir auch für die höheren
Lohngruppen also für Ingenieure die wir
dringend brauchen werden in den nächsten
Jahren für die ist es zu wenig also die
sind nicht wettbewerbsfähig es gibt ja
verschiedene Perspektiven auf den
Abschluss also die meisten Menschen
arbeiten sind selbst beschäftigt also
das ist jetzt die Perspektive auch für
diese 200 Millionen Menschen also ist
das in dieser Unterschiedlichkeit fährt
dann gibt's die Perspektive der
Gewerkschaften die Perspektive der Radis
bezahlen müssen der Städte lassen Sie
uns mal anfangen jetzt wirklich mit der
Frage für die Beschäftigten wir haben es
ungefähr verstanden glaube ich in den
unteren Lohngruppen sind es saftige
Erhöhungen das sind je nachdem wie man
rechnet bis zu 17 Prozent sagt der
gewerkschaftsvorsitzende wenn man Mittel
oder viel im öffentlichen Dienst
verdient dann sind es am Ende wirksam
nur etwas mehr als fünf Prozent also
eine ziemliche Spreizung viel für die
die wenig verdienen wenig für die die
oben verdienen ja ist das ein faires und
sinnvolles Ergebnis ja also ich finde
das insofern sinnvoll weil es ja so ist
dass die Leute die wenig verdienen sind
besonders hoch von der Inflation
betroffen man weiß ja dass man dann wenn
man wenig für den gibt man besonders
viel aus für Wohnen für Energie für
Nahrung was letztes Jahr alles so
wahnsinnig teuer geworden ist das heißt
in dieser Lohne speziell auf diese
Menschen zu gucken finde ich total
wichtig und es ist auch nicht ganz so
wie sie das sagten ich finde es insofern
ein bisschen schwierig weil die
Information ist jetzt wahnsinnig hoch
2022 sie ist dieses Jahr etwas niedriger
nach vielen Prognosen wird sie nächstes
Jahr eher so bei 3% liegen vermutlich
wir wissen es natürlich nicht
wie immer gibt es wenn drei Ökonomen
sechs Meinungen aber es sieht schon so
aus ob der Trend runter geht und dann
ist es sinnvoll mit so einer
inflationsprämie zu arbeiten die so eine
schockbelastung jetzt mal abfedert und
nicht voll darauf zu gehen auf eine
dauerhafte Erhöhung für immer weil dann
müssen sie auf dem Niveau kommen was für
die Arbeitgeber wirklich schwer zu
finanzieren wäre und das was jetzt die
die höher qualifizierten betrifft auf
die muss man schon gucken es sind mehr
als 6% Rechnung wie ich gesehen habe
wenn wir uns über den ganzen Zeit
umsieht sind schon so 8 9 %, ist jetzt
nicht schlecht die Leiden jetzt weniger
unter der Inflation und auf die muss man
in den nächsten Runden dann noch stärker
gucken aber es ist nicht so als ob die
jetzt kaum was kriegen würden da ist
schon also bei dem 8 9 % kann man jetzt
sagen direkt angesprochen
darf das sind die immensen real,-
denn das Problem ist ja gewesen der
letzte Tarifvertrag den der die
abgeschlossen hat das war 2002 in der
corona-krise der war wirklich
Entschuldigung
26 in der korother-krise und der war
wirklich so schlecht dass die Inflation
damit überhaupt nicht aufgefangen worden
ist und das muss eigentlich jetzt
nachgeholt werden und genau das ist aber
nicht passiert Frau Höning Herr Benzel
ich einmal nur zur sachklärung was frau
Krüger gesagt hat ist ja ein wichtiger
Punkt ist das Einvernehmen bei aller
Unterschiedlichkeit der Meinungen dass
insgesamt die Preissteigerungen der
letzten Jahre durch höhere Löhne und
Gehälter nicht ausgeglichen werden das
ist so aber es ist noch nicht Aufgabe
der Tarifpolitik
mit einem Abschluss aufzuheben der Chef
der IG Metall Jörg Hofmann hat das ja
auch ganz klar gesagt vor zwei Jahren
wir können nicht die ganzen
inflationsproblematiken auffangen aber
zurück zu dem Abschluss also wir müssen
glaube ich kein Mitleid jetzt mit den
unteren Lohngruppen haben auch die sind
wirklich gut bedacht worden durch diesen
Abschluss Müllwerker wir haben es gerade
schon auch in der Tagesschau
angesprochen hat
2600 Euro hat er bisher verdient er
bekommt jetzt 2018 Euro am Ende das ist
ja auch durchaus ein ordentlicher Schlag
drauf und dann ist es ja auch falsch zu
sagen die Menschen würden dies ja nichts
bekommen sie bekommen die
inflationsausgleichsprämie 2000 Euro
Unterschied
haben 3000 Euro
Steuer und Sozialabgaben frei über das
Jahr mehr in der Tasche das ist doch
wird aber es ist ordentlich
zur Kenntnis nehmen in der Tabelle ja
akademisch die Menschen haben das mehr
in der Tasche aber zurück zu der Frage
wir haben ja das Doppelte Problem zum
einen trifft die Inflation die unteren
Lohngruppen besonders stark deshalb muss
da auch absolut viel passieren ist ja
auch Geschehen auf der anderen Seite ist
der öffentliche Dienst natürlich im
scharfen Wettbewerb mit der Wirtschaft
und muss auch was für die oberen
Lohngruppen tun die Bauingenieure die im
Verkehrsamt fehlen bei der
neubaugenehmigung die müssen natürlich
auch entsprechend was bekommen
und die haben freie Auswahl also von
daher auch vor dem Hintergrund
ein vernünftiger abgewogener Abschluss
ich glaube man muss diese diese These
mit mit weniger werdenden Inflation
schon ein bisschen relativieren ich habe
doch mal geguckt wir hatten im März eine
Kerninflation von 5,8 Prozent und viele
Experten auch von der EZB sagen diese
Kerninflation die sich jetzt wirklich
tief sozusagen in die Ökonomie
reingefressen hat mit der werden wir
noch länger lange zu kämpfen haben und
die 5,8% sind halt 0,3% weniger als die
5,5% von denen wir die ganze Zeit
sprechen und das andere Thema wir haben
es jetzt schon mehrfach gehört Michael
Hüter vom IW also vom Institut der
deutschen Wirtschaft Arbeitgeber nah hat
gesagt wir haben eine lohnt triffst also
das heißt die Bruttolöhne steigen
stärker als die Tariflöhne und ähm das
ist ein sehr starkes Argument dafür dass
wir dass der öffentliche Dienst bei den
Fachkräften bei den Ingenieuren
tatsächlich in ernsthaftes Problem
bekommen wird und das ist in dieser
rohnlunde weil im öffentlichen Dienst
und bei diesem Abschluss praktisch
ausgeklammert worden
ich schließe das noch mal ab also aus
der Perspektive der Beschäftigten bei
aller Unterschiedlichkeit insgesamt
werden die meisten Menschen für ihr Geld
dass sie verdienen weniger kaufen können
in den nächsten Jahren weil die letzten
drei Jahre Corona Energiekrise Krieg
einfach letztlich uns alle
ärmer gemacht haben das können wir unter
dem Strich festhalten aber wie andere
Branchen auch die IG Metall
hatten Abschluss der ist prozentual
geringer als dieser Abschluss und da ist
er Frachten Sie warum sollte der hat
auch öffentliche Leben
warum kann der öffentliche Dienst sich
mehr leisten als die Metall und Elektro-
von der Regierung kommen es ist ja nicht
so dass die Leute voll die Inflation
spüren sondern es gab eine so ein
klecker-paket von allen möglichen
Entlastung letztes Jahr plus es gab die
Gas und strompreisbremse die im großen
Teil der Energie mehr Kosten abdeckt
sofern sie noch da sind das heißt die in
Millionen von vollen 7 Prozent ist nicht
voll abgegangen
ich wollte das gerade abschließen weil
ich werde ich ja auch weil ich ja auch
und sie anders teilweise schon getan es
gibt ja auch andere Perspektiven auf
diesen Abschluss danke übrigens dass sie
im Netz wieder dabei sind bei Presseclub
und Tagesschau auf unseren diversen
Kanälen in den sozialen Netzwerken da
gibt es eine Perspektive die sie auch
schon angesprochen haben im öffentlichen
Bereich sind hunderttausende
hunderttausende stellen jetzt schon
nicht besetzt viel in den Kommunen und
Gemeinden Ingo John weist darauf hin
dass es auch bei der Bundeswehr gilt die
dringend Soldaten Soldaten sucht also
wir sind auf einem Arbeitsmarkt auf dem
Menschen danach gucken können ob sie
mehr verdienen wenn sie woanders
hingehen der öffentliche Dienst ist
offenbar nicht so attraktiv wir merken
das als Bürger wenn unsere Anträge nicht
bearbeitet werden wenn Straßen nicht
gebaut werden können weil die Pläne
nicht da sind also vieles stockt jetzt
schon im Alltag was heißt dieser
Abschluss angesichts dieser Situation
für den öffentlichen Dienst für das was
wir als Bürgerinnen und Bürger erwarten
von unseren Städten Gemeinden Kreisen
ich würde das gar nicht so pessimistisch
sehen denn die oberen Lohngruppen
gar nicht so schlecht also das muss man
schon sehen wenn ein der Geschäftsführer
eines kommunalen Unternehmens im Monat
7.500 Euro hat dann oder 200 finde ich
das gar nicht so wenig die Frage des
Fachkräftemangels im öffentlichen Dienst
hängt vielleicht auch damit zusammen
dass der öffentliche Dienst aus anderen
Gründen nicht wirklich ein attraktiver
Arbeitgeber ist die Strukturen sind
verkrustet da hat das mit der
Digitalisierung überhaupt nicht
funktioniert die Leute sind überlastet
die haben mitunter keine guten
Aufstiegschancen und wenn er öffentliche
Dienst an attraktiver Arbeitgeber werden
möchte dann muss er glaube ich da
wirklich richtig dran arbeiten und für
viele Menschen ist es viel wichtiger in
gerade in den oberen Gehaltsgruppen als
mehr Geld verdienen wer 5000 Euro im
Monat hat okay also es ist keine
Geldfrage Frau Höning Herr Wenzel
Bedingungen im öffentlichen Dienst sind
ja sehr komfortabel als in der freien
Wirtschaft das mit Homeoffice und
Teilzeit noch gar nicht so verbreitet
war war da im öffentlichen Dienst schon
einiges möglich das Probleme öffentliche
Dienst ist ja die Flexibilität also dass
man außerhalb des Tarifvertrags auch
bezahlen muss etwa IT-Leute muss man
vielleicht anders bezahlen als andere
Akademiker dort das ist ein Problem des
öffentlichen Dienstes wo er auch
flexibler werden muss aber zu sagen der
öffentliche Dienst ist hat keine
Ausschließung das ist ja so formalisiert
im öffentlichen Dienst viel mehr als in
der Wirtschaft und der steht halt im
fliegt wo sie Recht haben ist das Thema
Digitalisierung
Digitalisierung fährt der öffentliche
Dienst seiner Rendite überhaupt nicht
ein und wenn er das machen würde dann
hätten die Kommunen und der Hund auch
mehr Mittel und die Leute die dann
arbeiten entsprechen zu bezahlen ich sag
mal ein Beispiel die Bundesanstalt für
Arbeit hat fast noch immer so viele
Mitarbeiter wie zu Hochzeiten der
Arbeitslosigkeit fünf Millionen da wäre
es ja super wenn man wenn die die
digitalisierungsdividende einfahren
würden Stellen abbauen würden und die
Menschen die da sind entsprechend
beschäftigen und solche Beispiele lassen
sich auch sicher in Kommunen Herr Wenzel
ist dran ich denke gerade an ein
Gespräch ich habe jemanden getroffen der
in einer Behörde für
it also für Computertechnik für
digitales zuständig ist und der mir
erklärt hat dass er nicht halbwegs die
Leute hat die er braucht weil einige
tausend Euro mehr in den meisten Jobs in
Unternehmen zu verdienen sind und der
sagt mit der Digitalisierung geht's
nicht voran ist klar aber wir haben
keine Leute die zu uns kommen aber sie
sind dran also das ist schon ein Punkt
die Digitalisierung und das ist auch
übrigens ein Punkt wo nach meiner
Erfahrung und nachdem was ich auch so
gehört habe in den letzten Jahren von
Bürgermeister und Kommunalpolitikern da
auch eine wichtige Rolle spielt dass die
einfach nicht den Mut haben
Digitalisierung voranzutreiben weil das
würde ja bedeuten dass man da ziemlich
Aufruhr erzeugen muss erstmal oder oder
Verwirrung sagen wir mal in
Rathäusern und in
Kreisverwaltungen also da man könnte ja
mich vor vielen Jahren gab es das Thema
schon mal man könnte die Kfz-Zulassung
komplett streichen zum Beispiel also
dann würde der Staat 800 Milliarden
jedes Jahr
einsparen und man könnte das den
Versicherungen die ja sowieso die Autos
versichern müssen überlassen aber
welcher Landrat hat den Mut seiner
Kfz-Zulassungsstelle zu sagen ab Anfang
ab
2024 gibt es euch nicht mehr dann beugt
sich keiner dran also das ist natürlich
auch eine Aufgabe die künftig auf die
kommunalen und staatlichen Arbeitgeber
zukommen und das müssen sie tun weil ich
glaube was sie eben gesagt haben die das
ist gar nicht so schlimm ich glaube es
ist ziemlich schlimm also was die was
das ausscheidende Babyboomer aus dem
öffentlichen Dienst angeht und da geht's
nicht nur um die Ingenieure und um die
hochbezahlten Geschäftsführer sondern
das geht ja nicht die ganze Struktur
durch also das geht auf die
Sachbearbeiter Ebene also wo jemand in
der Behörde sitzt ja seit 20 Jahren weiß
wie man Windräder
genehmigen muss aber sich jetzt nicht
mehr traut weil er Angst hat verklagt zu
werden aber der weiß wenigstens wie es
geht und die Leute muss man auch alles
finden und die Leute sind gleichzeitig
bei einem windanlagenbauern natürlich
also jemand der das weiß der sich da
auskennt hoch begehrt also die die
hat mir jemand aus der Branche erzählt
die Leute
arbeiten sich von einem Job zum anderen
mit gehörigen
Gehaltserhöhungen jetzt so durch die
Branche durch und ähm die sagen öffent
sieht es nichts für uns ich würde ja gar
kein Gegensatz sehen also natürlich ist
es wichtig dass da die Digitalisierung
vorangetrieben wird nicht zuletzt auch
vielleicht für uns als Bürger hätten wir
gerne mehr Leistung digital die drin
Versprechung ist immer gibt aber ich
glaube dass man trotzdem die höher
qualifizierten deutlich besser bezahlen
muss es geht ja eben wie gesagt nicht
nur um Geschäftsführer von unserem
Unternehmen das ist natürlich die Top
Leute aber um die ganzen anderen
Fachkräfte auch weil wir müssen ja die
die ganze Perspektive sehen der
Personalmangel umfasst eben die gesamte
Wirtschaft also auch die ganzen
privatwirtschaftlichen Unternehmen die
eben mit höheren Löhnen um dieses diese
Beschäftigten Pokern was wir jetzt die
letzten Jahrzehnte ja nicht so gesehen
haben und wenn der öffentliche Dienst
dazu zurück bleibt dann werden eben die
Leute fehlen weil es glaube ich
tendenziell so ist dass diese höher
qualifizierten in der Wirtschaft im
Zweifel auf verschiedenen Wegen noch
besser verdienen sei es über Tarife sei
es über Zulagen über und so weiter und
so fort da tut sich eine Firma natürlich
viel leichter als als der Staat mit den
ganz komplizierten Regelwerk einfach zu
sagen hey du kriegst eine Prämie wenn du
überhaupt auftauchst oder wenn du zum
Bewerbungsgespräch kommst oder du machst
deinen Job von aus Quakenbrück und die
Firma Sitze München no problem und unter
der öffentliche Arbeitgeber muss jetzt
erstmal die 300 seitigen
Ausführungsbestimmung lesen ob er sowas
überhaupt erlauben darf oder nicht und
deswegen ich glaube ich würde es total
produziert anders ich glaube wir
brauchen für die höher qualifizierten
die Leute damit wir auch ganz viel
schaffen können Klima und Energiewende
da brauchen wir die ganzen Fachleute
Bildung haben wir große Rückstände noch
größere Rückstände bekommen jetzt in der
corona-krise für unser Land also die
Digitalisierung des Schulunterrichts bei
meinen Kindern in der in der
corona-krise möchte ich jetzt nicht
überleben also da muss was passieren
wenn es darum geht tatsächlich für die
Menschen die wenig Geld verdienen da
erhebliche Fortschritte zu schaffen dann
sagen alle das kann man sich nicht
leisten die Kommunen haben kein Geld bei
dieser Frage spielt es dann
offensichtlich nicht mehr so eine große
Rolle und das finde ich schon sehr
auffällig denn
man muss ja auch sehen auch bei denen
wirklich gut verdienenden es gibt der es
gibt eine gute Altersvorsorge es gibt
eine ganze Reihe von Zulagen und so das
ist ja nicht so dass die die besser
finden dann im öffentlichen Dienst total
abgehängt sind und ich finde man sollte
auch nicht so ich fasse mal zusammen
trotzdem haben wir ja heute schon viele
leere Büros und Planstellen also einige
hunderttausend verschiedene
Wirtschaftsinstitute gehen davon aus
dass das in wenigen Jahren eine Million
unbesetzte Stellen im öffentlichen
Bereich sein können also Fakt ist die
Leute wollen dort nicht arbeiten
gleichzeitig beklagen jetzt aber die
Kommunen den teuersten Abschluss der
Geschichte 15 bis 17 Milliarden Euro
mehr kosten in diesem und im nächsten
Jahr bei den Kommunen gibt es sehr
wohlhabende die das können aber eben
auch viele dies nicht können heute
leistet der Staat für uns schon bei
weitem nicht was wir erwarten das haben
wir in den letzten Jahren gemerkt also
vieles was wir brauchen passiert nicht
was heißt das denn jetzt was ist denn
daraus jetzt abzuleiten und zu erwarten
vor allen Dingen der Abschluss ist ja 17
Milliarden hat Frau Welge ja
vorgerechnet die Verhandlungsführerin
der Kommunen davon 14 Milliarden also
laufend drei Milliarden sind die
Einmalzahlung 14 Milliarden laufen das
ist natürlich in Wort gerade für die
Armen Kommunen wie Gelsenkirchen wo sie
ja herkommt und die Kommunen haben wir
von Anfang an schon gewarnt wenn ihr das
überzieht müssen wir Leistung kürzen
oder Gebühren erhöhen das sind ja die
beiden Stellschrauben die die haben und
es ähm sie haben jetzt im Abschluss
zugestimmt aber auf lange Sicht werden
das arme Kommunen natürlich überlegen
nicht umsonst hat ja eine Stadt wie
Duisburg besonders hohe Kita Beiträge da
wird man das dann konkret merken oder
auch einmal Abwassergebühren sind oft
Arme Städte die teuersten das ähm bringt
umso mehr zum äh die Notwendigkeit auf
den Tisch dass man guckt dass man auch
einspart und da sage ich nochmal gerne
Stichwort digitalisierungs Dividende
wenn ihr Digitalisierung macht dann
spart doch auch die Leute ein zum
Beispiel in der Finanzverwaltung die
ging es jetzt nicht aber es ist so ein
plakatives Beispiel da machen doch so
viele Leute mittlerweile ihre Erklärung
mit ELSTER haben die die
finanzfarbeamten eine Frage weil ich sie
auch hier bei Facebook und in
Kommentaren immer wieder lese das ist
die Zustandsbeschreibung aber was
passiert jetzt wer bezahlt das jetzt
oder wird es nicht bezahlt machen die
Kommunen einfach zum Teil ihrer
Leistungen also die Schulden werden
steigen es werden noch mehr Kommunen
verschuldungsprobleme bekommen Kommunen
werden ihre Leistungen einschränken da
gehe ich schon von aus die haben ja von
der Schmerzgrenze gesprochen das ist ja
Durchschnitt also werden die armen
Kommunen teilweise Leistung einschränken
und ähm sie werden sich da so nach der
Decke strecken müssen und sie müssen
gegen steuern indem sie sparen also ich
möchte doch mal an eine Gruppe sozusagen
erinnern die wir bislang noch gar nicht
den Blick genommen haben nämlich
Erzieherinnen Menschen die sich um
Flüchtlinge kümmern Mensch Menschen die
sich um Migranten kümmern also diese
erziehungsbildungsintegrations
Ausgaben man kann mit Digitalisierung
einiges machen aber das können wir mit
Digitalisierung nur sehr beschränkt
machen und da werden die Aufgaben also
wenn wir in Einwanderung sein Land sein
wollen dann werden da die Aufgaben
massiv steigen also das ist eine
Dimension die wir heute die wir heute
noch gar nicht rechnen kann sozusagen
und und da kommt dann sagt man mal an
der Kreisverwaltung in der Uckermark
kann das schon ganz schön den Schleudern
kommen also ich glaube wir müssen früher
oder später darüber nachdenken wie
Kommunion wie Kommunen anders finanziert
ja früher ne also ja genau ich würde
sagen eher schnell also ich glaube es
gibt zwei große Sachen es gibt ja diese
Kluft die wir jetzt gesehen haben die
Bundesregierung hatte das Geld vor Weser
ist immer schon raus an die mikroskant
hat gesagt 8 % ist okay während dieser
Kommunen im Saal sagten wieso denn so
muss man sagen dass der Bund relativ
unbetroffen ist ne also der Hund hat
innerhalb eines wenig Ausgaben versuchen
Personal er hat gesagt also das meine
mit der Kluft und auf der anderen Seite
gibt es auch Kommunen die sehr viel Geld
haben die sagen hey wir wollen die
Fachkräfte wann und dann gibt es die
Kommunen mit den Problemen Gelsenkirchen
da ist die fahndungsführerin im Osten in
der Rheinland-Pfalz deswegen glaube ich
brauchen wir zwei Dinge das erste ist
dass wir darüber nachdenken müssen und
eine Reform dieser Finanzierung weil die
Gewerbesteuer natürlich dazu führt wenn
sie plötzlich bei und Tag haben ja in
Mainz dann wissen Sie gar nicht wohin
mit der Kohle und das passiert aber eben
nicht in Gelsenkirchen das heißt man
muss überlegen wie die Gemeinde
vielleicht teilweise anders das Geld
bekommen über da gibt's ja eine
formvorschläge über umsatzsteueranteile
und so weiter und das zweite ist ich
glaube es braucht eine
altschuldenregelung für für viele
Gemeinden beispielsweise in
Nordrhein-Westfalen und auch in
Rheinland-Pfalz da hat sich Olaf Scholz
stark gemacht dafür als er noch
Finanzminister war es steht auch was im
Koalitionsvertrag Linda hatte jetzt
bisher noch nicht viel blicken lassen
ich glaube die müssen einen Teil dieser
er als Schulden abgenommen bekommen
unter bestimmten Bedingungen weil es
kann wirklich nicht sein dass die
Alternative ist auch für künftige
Verhandlungsrunden nicht mehr Geld für
die ganzen Erzieherinnen und so weiter
die wir brauchen
oder eben mehr Geld aber dann wird an
den Leistungen gekürzt ausgerechnet in
den Ländern die einen Städten die die
Infrastruktur nicht haben dann ganz kurz
bitte noch weil ich wird das Thema gern
abschließen wobei man da auch aufpassen
muss dass man jetzt nicht immer die
armen Kommunen bedauert die ja kein Geld
haben das hat ja auch wahnsinnig viele
Verschwendung gegeben wir erinnern uns
an die Spaßbäder die überall entstanden
sind
woran einfach gesagt die haben sich
übernommen Punkt angenommen sie hatten
schon zu dem Thema noch ein Kind von
ihnen nur darauf hinweisen dass die
Kommunen ja auch profitieren von der
Inflation also sie bekommen ja auch mehr
Einnahmen und da ist die Frage ob man
nicht in der Tat andere
Verteilungsschlüssel in der Zukunft hat
um den Kommunen mehr Spielräume zu
ermöglichen denn die Vorstellung dass zu
den ganzen anderen Kosten jetzt auch
noch höhere kommunale Gebühren kommen
dass das kann nicht die Lösung sein also
ich halte fest schon heute leisten die
Gemeinden nicht was er von ihnen
erwarten die Schere wird zunehmen es
gibt eine ungleiche Grenzverteilung und
wenn im Gesamtstaat nicht mehr Geld an
die Kommunen gegeben wird werden sie
eben noch mehr Aufgaben für uns nicht
erledigen können ich habe es eingangs
gesagt wir haben mit dem öffentlichen
Dienst hier ohne die Länder sicherlich
einen sehr sehr großen Tarifbereich aber
es gab und ein Dutzend Branchen die in
diesem Jahr Tarifverhandlungen geführt
haben die meisten sind abgeschlossen
und wird es deshalb gerne ein bisschen
öffnen etwas was auch unsere Userin User
sehr beschäftigt und was bei fast allen
Tarifabschlüssen der Schlüssel war ist
diese
inflationsausgleichsprämie die
Bundesregierung hat ein Gesetz erlassen
mit dem Bundestag im vergangenen Jahr
nachdem Arbeitgeber 3000 Euro Steuer und
sozialabgabenfrei in einem bestimmten
Zeitraum zahlen dürfen und das ist in
den Tarifverhandlungen auch jetzt
vielfältig genutzt worden also auch das
erste Jahr 2023 jetzt in diesem
Tarifabschluss kommt im Wesentlichen aus
diesem Geld und ist deshalb so wertvoll
weil es brutto für netto ist und man
dann sozusagen das Gefühl hat man hat
mehr auf den Tisch gelegt was in
Wirklichkeit die Sozialversicherungen
und das Finanzamt bezahlen
das ist ja ein ganz spannendes
Instrument und es gibt auch Menschen die
Fragen im Netz ist das überhaupt
zulässig dass der Staat Tarifverträge
auf diese Art und Weise finanziert wie
ist so ihre Meinung dazu war das in
dieser Tarifrunde gerne Herr Wenzel
war das der Schlüssel also hat sozusagen
die Bundesregierung dazu beigetragen
dass wir jetzt nicht wilde Streiks
bekommen also ich glaube es war eine
Brücke also das war Röcke oder eine
Brücke eine Krücke okay eine Krücke es
sollte eine Brücke sein ja es ist
eigentlich eine Krücke nach meiner
Einschätzung weil
bei Verdi zum Beispiel wurde es so
gedacht was sie jetzt kriegen diese drei
diese 3000 Euro über viele Etappen
verteilt sozusagen als eine
Rückvergütung für die Belastungen die
sie im letzten Jahr hatten also damit
soll sozusagen das leere Konto wieder
aufgefüllt werden und dann gucken wir
mal wie es weitergeht und ich glaube
diese Funktion hat dieses Instrument
tatsächlich für viele Beschäftigte das
heißt dass das sollte man eigentlich zur
Seite schieben und sagen wir müssen
jetzt mal gucken wie es weitergeht also
wie können wir
Kaufkraft stärken und dann sind wir
wieder bei den 5,5% und 200 € Basis ich
möchte ihn widersprechen ich finde es
nicht als Krücke sondern ich finde es
als Brücke und zwar eine die ich sehr
stabil war und die ja wirklich von allen
Branchen begangen wurde es war vor dem
Hintergrund der ist Ukraine Kriegs
gemacht auch vor dem Hintergrund dass
man nicht genau wusste wie es weitergeht
und auch wir wollen uns jetzt nicht über
die einzelnen Zahlen streiten aber die
Inflation geht ja runter die EZB hat
ihre Hausaufgaben begriffen und macht
sie und deshalb war das wirklich klug
vom Bund aus Reise mal von der Ampel gut
gemacht die Tarifbeschäftigten da so
durchzuführen das sind ohne diese Brücke
Krücke hätten die Kommunen eben drei
Milliarden mehr zu schultern gehabt
dauerhaft und das ist die entlassen bin
total und Post also
gut weil es einfach Zeit gibt für dieses
Jahr kommt bei den Beschäftigten
trotzdem an und die Branchen haben Zeit
sich neu zu sortieren auf die neuen
Lagen ist das gerecht
etwa knapp die Hälfte der Beschäftigten
sind in Deutschland von solchen
Tarifverträgen betroffen
da wird es verabredet wenn ich nicht in
dem Tarifvertrag bin ist es mein Glück
ob meine Chefin oder mein Chef mir das
zahlt also
insofern ist es ist einfach ein Geschenk
an diejenigen die Tarifverträge machen
und die anderen gucken in die Röhre also
ich glaube schon dass es in gewisser
Weise ein Geschenk an die Gewerkschaften
gewesen ist die dadurch größeren
Handlungsspielraum bekommen haben wenn
auch die Gewerkschaften das als
vergiftetes Geschenk betrachtet haben
denn was ja passiert ist dass es
sozusagen
alternativ statt einer Lohnerhöhung
angewandt wird das finde ich auch nicht
gut aber das Instrument an sich ist
wirklich gut denn es ermöglicht wirklich
den Arbeitgebern den Beschäftigten
schnell Geld zur Verfügung zu stellen
und das ist das was viele Leute jetzt
brauchen die mit den mit den hohen
Energiepreisen kämpfen und mit den
anderen hohen Preisen und es ist ja
nicht nur möglich eben in
tarifgebundenen Unternehmen das
anzuwenden sondern da wo es dann
tatsächlich auch
Arbeitnehmervertretungen gibt oder
vielleicht auch Arbeitgeber die wissen
dass sie auf diese Art und Weise ihren
Beschäftigten einfach relativ günstig
helfen können bitte ich würde sagen es
auch ein Geschenk an die Arbeitgeber
gewesen warum weil wenn man jetzt diesen
Druck den die Arbeitnehmer gespürt
hätten für die Inflation durch lohnerung
zu finanzieren wirklich komplett durch
Lohnerhöhung die dauerhaft wirken
finanzieren hätte müssen dann werden
diese Abschlüsse die prozentualen noch
deutlich höher ausgefallen mit hohen
Kosten die sofort kamen in IG Metall-
die haben Ende letzten Jahres
abgeschlossen dass noch keiner wusste ob
es gasmangel im Winter gibt und die
Firmen vielleicht gar nicht produzieren
können das hätte eine ziemliche
Katastrophe unter Umständen gegeben und
das waren weil es ja ein ökonomischer
Schock von außen war die Inflation durch
den Ukraine Krieg vor allem in dem
Moment was einzusetzen in die Tarifrunde
war sehr schlau und jetzt kann man dann
weitermachen mit den normalen Erhöhung
kann da weitergehen und wenn es eben die
Leute nicht bekommen die nicht eben im
Tarif sind ist es vielleicht auch ja für
die Arbeitnehmer an als über
nachzudenken Stärke ich vielleicht eine
Gewerkschaft indem ich da Beiträge und
die beitrete und in dem die eben
Tarifverträge auch für mich mit
organisiert ist vielleicht Nebeneffekt
und wo jeder eben versteht dass er damit
vielleicht auch was positives ist nicht
für sie tun würde ein geschicktes
Instrument jedenfalls das eine
vielfältige Wirkung hat das ja auch ein
bisschen sag mal Ausgleich für die
besser verdienenden ist weil die
natürlich mehr davon haben wenn sie
keine Steuern und
Sozialabgaben davon bezahlen müssen also
das ist so ein bisschen so Gegeneffekt
zu der Stärkung der unteren Lohngruppen
der verdi-vorsitzende Wernicke wirkte ja
nicht komplett glücklich diese Nacht der
hat schöne zahlen das haben wir in der
Tagesschau gehört vorgerechnet aber er
hat auch durchaus zu erkennen gegeben
dass Verdi andere Vorstellungen gehabt
hatte ja die haben 10,5 eine stärker
ausgeprägte soziale Komponente gewünscht
und auch das ist nicht gelungen ist eine
Altersteilzeitregelung zu verlängern die
ist bislang gab ist für uns schmerzhaft
lassen Sie uns am nicht am Ende aber ich
sag mal so kurz vor dem Ende der
Tarifrunde dieses Jahres ein bisschen
kommt ja noch aber sag mal das
Wesentliche ist durch mal auf die Rolle
der Gewerkschaften gucken also wer die
hat und ein Drittel der Mitglieder in
den letzten 20 Jahren verloren hat ein
bisschen jetzt gegensteuern können weil
das Auftreten der Tarifrunde neue
Mitglieder gebracht hat aber sag mal
schon ziemlich Backen aufgepustet und am
Ende bleibt doch eine große Zahl die
gefordert wurde und
etwas was nicht so groß wirkt jedenfalls
macht er selbst den Eindruck bitte der
Rente ja das ist das kann Problem werden
für wer die also ich bin mal gespannt
ich habe am Freitag gehört dass die
Stimmung innerhalb der Gewerkschaft und
auch bei den
Funktionären durchaus gemischt war also
es gab so ein Drittel ein bisschen
Viertel
von Verdi Leuten die gesagt haben wir
wollen mehr und wir müssen eigentlich
auch mehr wohnen weil wir haben im
Moment ja eine praktische historisch
einmaliges Situation also wir haben
dieses
arbeitskräfteproblem und wir haben eine
hohe Inflation also wenn ich jetzt wann
dann gibt es muss hohe Abschlüsse geben
die wirklich real lohnwirksam werden und
ich bin mal sehr gespannt wie die
Diskussion jetzt weitergeht und ähm wir
werden ja nächste Woche am Dienstag
Verhandlungen der Eisenbahner
Gewerkschaft EVG sehen die noch ein
bisschen
verschiedene rangehen die sagen
mindestens 650 Euro und 12 Prozent und
die wollen sich auch nicht darauf
einlassen sich an das an das jetzige
öffentliche Dienst Ende oder das
Ergebnis anzuschließen also da steht uns
auch noch was bevor und ich glaube da
ist jetzt auch sozusagen Druck bei den
Gewerkschaften
und im Moment wo sich die Arbeitgeber
Verhandlungen hinstellen sagt der
teuerste Abschluss aller Zeiten und er
sitzt Grinsen an der Kamera und sagt
genau und wir haben es euch ausgeholt ja
er muss natürlich bei so einem Ergebnis
dann immer auch sagen ja für uns auch
schmerzhaften so aber ich glaube dass er
die da viel rausgeholt hat also wenn man
sich das anschaut auch mit anderen
Abschlüssen vergleicht die haben schon
mehr rausgeholt über die Stärke als die
IG Metall die in den ganz starke Basis
in den Betrieben hat es ist so das wäre
die Leute mobilisiert die haben 80.000
Mitglieder gewonnen neue Mitglieder das
ist seit Jahren und Patienten nicht
passiert in ihrem Form weil die Leute
das Gefühl hat in der verdammt eine
Million verloren über 20 genau über 20
Jahre und so eine Gegenbewegung gab es
bisher wieder bei Verdi noch in der
anderen Gewerkschaft in den letzten
Jahren weil die Arbeitnehmer das Gefühl
hatten da ist jemand für uns jetzt da in
so einem inflationsmoment deswegen sind
die Leute auf die Straße gegangen und es
ist so das glaube ich diese
Personalmangel Frage die Sie
angesprochen haben ist kein historischer
Moment der auf das Jahr 2023 beschränkt
ist sondern das wird weitergehen und da
ist es natürlich wir werden auch wichtig
die Sozialpartnerschaft mit dem Kommunen
und dem Bund zu erhalten weil wenn man
das ganze überzieht und das hätte jetzt
einen Platz in der Schlichtung gegeben
und unbefristete Streiks sowas hatten
wir auch schon mal 1992 da muss die
Gewerkschaft in diesem alten
Schlichtungsvorschlag erstmal hinterher
streichen 1992 haben die das kaum wieder
erreicht das was der Schlichter
vorgeschlagen hatte und dann waren die
Leute richtig sauer weil dann sind sie
nämlich nochmal auf die Straße gegangen
elf Tage es kam kaum mehr raus als die
5,4 % die der schläft ja damals
vorgeschlagen hatte und die Leute sind
massiv ausgetreten ich glaube dass es
für Verdi gut gelaufen ist die Strategie
von Frank Wernig ist aufgegangen glaube
ich und es gibt ja eben die nächsten
lohnungen wo man mit dem Personalmangel
wieder wuchern kann wer meine Analyse
insgesamt eine Lohnrunde gehabt die sag
mal in guter Tradition der
Bundesrepublik ein guter Kompromiss war
oder ist die Befürchtung berechtigt dass
die Lohnerhöhungen so sind dass sie
wieder preiserhöhungen nach sich ziehen
und wir in eine gefährliche Spirale
kommen das war ja die große Sorge der
Ökonomen das ist dieser lohnpreisspirale
kommt Gott sei Dank hat auch wer die die
Kurve gekriegt und hat wie die IG Metall
und wie Chemie am Ende einen Abschluss
getroffen der die lohnpreisspirale nicht
über Gebühr anreizt auch unter
Ausnutzung der 3000 der
inflationsausgleichsprämie gleichwohl
von der Güte des Arbeitskampfes her war
das natürlich grenzwertig und das wusste
wer die auch ähm es hat noch nie gegeben
dass so viele waren Streiks als 24
Stunden Streiks stattfand die wir
erinnern uns an die Pendler die immer
wieder 24 Stunden nicht transportiert
wurden an die armen Familien die in der
corona-krise schon genug gelitten hatten
und ihre Kinder wieder nicht in die Kita
schicken konnten da hat wer die Neuland
betreten die haben geguckt wie weit sie
gehen können und es die Stimmung drohte
ja zu kippen es hat Umfragen gegeben
dass die Bevölkerung sagt wir verstehen
die Lohnerhöhung aber die Mehrheit sagt
wir verstehen nicht mehr diese Streiks
und das Problem hätte sich ja verschärft
wenn die jetzt eine Urabstimmung
eingeleitet hätten ich glaube dass es
für vertie sehr schwer sein wird diesen
Tarifabschluss wirklich zu vermitteln
ich glaube dass die Beschäftigten sehr
enttäuscht sein werden und sagen werden
das ist nicht das wofür wir gewarnt
streikt haben
10,5 % und jetzt kriegen die Hälfte das
ist eben ein übliches Spiel dass die
Forderungen eben sehr hoch gestellt
werden da sollte man vielleicht auch mal
drüber nachdenken ob das wirklich so
sinnvoll ist weil man hinterher ein
Kommunikationsproblem hat und das das
hat wer die jetzt und da ist natürlich
auch die Gefahr dass die Mitglieder die
neu gekommen sind auch ganz schnell
wieder weg sind die Frage ist ja nur was
wäre die Alternative gewesen also die
Alternative wäre ja vielleicht ein
Streik gewesen aber ob wir die das
durchgehalten hätte und mir rausgeholt
hätte da muss man wirklich viele
Fragezeichen machen denn wenn wir
1992 denken da war das ja so da gab es
zwölf Tage Streik das Ergebnis war nicht
wirklich besser als der Schlichter
Spruch und das war ein Desaster für die
damalige ÖTV und das wäre die sich das
ersparen will das ist nachvollziehbar
wir sind oder kommen in die Schlussrunde
deshalb noch mal so sag mal Strich
drunter und Blick nach vorne können wir
weiterhin stolz darauf sein wie
arbeitgeber und Gewerkschaften in der
Regel gute Wege finden auch wenn es
diesmal ein bisschen aggressiver
zugegangen ist vielleicht bei der Bahn
noch mal Receiver zugeht aber das kennen
wir seit Jahren also können wir
insgesamt zufrieden sein oder ist das ja
jetzt nur ein Notnagel ein fauler
Kompromiss und es bricht großer Unmut
und Streit in den nächsten Jahren auf
ich glaube wir können halb zufrieden
sein also einerseits was sie gerade
gesagt haben es wäre es hätte in der
Katastrophe enden können also wenn
dieser schlichter Spruch nicht
angenommen worden wäre also für wer die
wohl gemerkt
jetzt haben wir auch den Bürgern jede
Menge
Ärger vom Hals gehalten aber wir haben
gleichzeitig ein grundlegendes Problem
verschoben nämlich wie sie eben gesagt
haben auch die nächste Runde wir werden
in wir werden in zwei Jahren dieses
Thema wieder aufrufen wir werden
vielleicht noch mehrfach- und
Arbeitskräfte Mangel haben und wir
werden vielleicht noch eine höhere
Forderung von der Gewerkschaft bekommen
und dann beginnt das Spiel von vorne und
wie das dann ausgeht das wird sehr
spannend ja Einsatz darf jeder noch wir
sind am Ende nicht genau also ich glaube
dass unser System gezeigt hat dass es
funktioniert ich weiß nicht wie viele
Manager entführt worden werden in
Frankreich oder Reifen gebannt hätten
oder sowas bei diesem Konflikten ist
gegeben hat und es wird eine neue Art
von Arbeitskämpfen geben wegen des
personalange ein bisschen beide Seiten
mit klar kommen und nicht überziehen ein
noch kürzerer Satz vor allen Dingen die
Zahl ist in Ordnung die Streitkultur ist
nicht in Ordnung so eine streiksaison
darf sich nicht wiederholen und ich
finde die Ergebnisse enttäuschend weil
es eben keinen wirklichen reallust
Ausgleich gibt ja bedanke mich sehr
herzlich für diese Runde versuche noch
mal
zusammenzufassen wir haben konstatiert
es war in den Tarifrunden dieses Jahres
nicht möglich wenn es jetzt hier gewesen
sein sollte den Kaufkraftverlust der
letzten Jahre auszugleichen ein bisschen
ist es jetzt Glaskugel mit dem Blick
nach vorne ob es ein Beispiel dafür ist
wie guter Ausgleich funktioniert und am
Ende dann doch alle zufrieden sind oder
ob die Unzufriedenheit der Unterschied
zwischen Forderungen und Erfüllung dann
doch zu groß bedanke mich sehr herzlich
in der ARD folgt jetzt wie immer das
europamagazin heute mit einer Ausgabe
die sich nur mit der Situation auf dem
Westbalkan
befasst das ist sicher spannend wenn Sie
hier weiter mit diskutieren wollen im
Radio bei WDR 5 im Fernsehen bei Phoenix
und im Netz kommt Presseclub nachgefragt
danke fürs dabei sein tschüss lassen
sich gut gehen
[Musik]
und willkommen zurück Presseclub
nachgefragt im Fernsehen bei Phoenix im
Radio bei WDR 5 und auf vielen Kanälen
im Netz in der Leitung ist aus Aalen ich
nehme an es ist allen in Westfalen ein
gutes anders willkommen
guten Tag Amelie Sander ich bin halb
französisch
71 bzw 81a wir staunen über diese
Vertragsabschluss wir halten ehrlich
gesagt die Forderungen von Verdi und
erst recht jetzt von der EVG für eine
absolute Unverschämtheit wir Rentner
leiden auch unter der Inflation wir
beziehen eine eigentlich ganz
ordentliche Rente wenn man und ich davon
konnte man früher auch gut leben nicht
luxurius aber gut aber wir kriegen keine
3400 € als Ausgleichszahlung und unsere
Rentenerhöhung wird sich Abhören ob
Sommer und unter 5% bewegen und wir
brauchen auch was zu Essen und zu
Trinken Zusatzzahlung für Ausgaben weil
der krank sind wer bezahlt uns denn das
ich finde das aus Sicht der Rentner und
auch sich das Steuerzahlers der ja
letztlich das alles bezahlen muss für
nicht gleichzeitig ich danke Ihnen Frau
Sanders für dieses klare Statement ich
glaube sie sind nicht die einzige die in
diese Richtung denkt ich gehe mal direkt
weiter nach Chemnitz in Sachsen zu
Janine Aurich hallo Frau Aurich
schließen Sie sich gerne an ja ich kann
das nur unterstreichen auch das ist mein
Anliegen ich freue mich für jeden
Beschäftigten der von der Tariferhöhung
partizipiert aber ich habe weder in der
Presse noch im Fernsehen jemals etwas
gehört wie wir Rentner eine
Inflationsausgleich bekommen sollen und
da hätte ich gerne gewusst was sie
angeht sind Journalisten dazu sagen ja
es rührt sich auch was am Tisch
vielen Dank für die Fragen das ist ja in
der Tat eine neue perspekt hoffe dazu
kann man sagen dass es für die
Rentnerinnen und Rentner und Pensionäre
natürlich keine
inflationsausgleichsprämie gibt aber
auch sie werden am Ende profitieren die
Rentenerhöhungen resultieren ja aus den
Lohnsteigerungen der Vorjahre und das
was jetzt bei den Beschäftigten ankommt
wird sich auf Dauer auch bei den
Rentnern und Pensionären in ausgleichen
niederschlagen so ist ja die
Konstruktion der
Rentenerhöhung aber gilt das auch für
diese 3000 Euro also wird das auch davon
werden keine Rentenbeiträge bezahlt also
kann sich das dann auswirken es wird ja
auf die Lohnsumme Entwicklung geschaut
das Vorjahres und da zahlt das ja darauf
ein auch wenn es nicht tabellenwirksam
ist also sie müssen sich leider noch ein
bisschen gedulden und vielleicht über
die Energiepreis pauschale freuen die
die Rentner und Pensionäre dann ja im
Nachgang auch bekommen haben und dann
zieht es sich durch sie müssen sich
gedulden
ja okay danke
wir gehen weiter nach Rossdorf zu Daniel
Herold hallo Herold bekommen
jetzt sehen ist Ergebnis gewesen eines
Arbeitskampfes und einer Schlichtung und
im Arbeitskampf ist es zu Streiks
bekommen ich persönlich hielt die
Streiks für legitim vor allen Dingen
legal und angemessen
mich hat sehr erschüttert dass relativ
schnell medial teilweise auch von
Politikern
nach meinem Empfinden eine Beschränkung
des Streikrechts eingefordert worden ist
und da wollte die Runde mal fragen wie
Sie das sehen ob er das schrecklich
jetzt wirklich
eingeschränkt werden muss ob das jetzt
eine Situation ist mit der beleben
können insbesondere vor dem Hintergrund
das ist ja möglicherweise auch zur
Arbeit Kämpfen bei der nächsten Runde
für die Bahn kommen könnte ja spannende
Frage danke ich habe ja hier bei
nachgefragt immer das Prinzip das nur
einer aus der Runde erwidern darf jetzt
haben sich alle gemeldet von wem hätten
sie gerne antworten
auf einer Süddeutschen Zeitung
ja also ich will nicht dafür dass
Streikrecht einzuschränken wir haben die
Situation dass wir die starkrechte
Arbeitnehmer haben das haben andere
Länder nicht gibt viele Milliarden
Menschen auf der Welt die nicht streiten
können und das was wir sehen ist nicht
so unverhältnismäßig aus meiner Sicht
dass man das Streikrecht einsteigen
sollte es kann immer irgendwelche
anderen Situationen geben in der Zukunft
dann muss man über Themen vielleicht
reden oder über einzelne Regularien aber
das was in den letzten Wochen und
Monaten erlebt haben rechtfertig auf
keinen Fall eine Einstellung ist jemand
anderer Meinung nein sie sind andere
Meinung gut dann halten wir das fest
dass sie anderer Meinung sind
bedanke mich herzlich spannender Aspekt
Gruß nach Südhessen
und in thaila ist Alexa guten Tag
Ärger ja ich glaube kann es sein dass
sie irgendwie im Hintergrund noch ein
Gerät laufen haben ich glaube jetzt wird
es besser bitte fangen sie an
ja guten Tag mein Name ist Axel mager
aus Tholey es ging ja bei den aktuellen
Tarifverhandlungen darum
Kaufkraftverluste zu vermeiden das heißt
Ausgleiche zu schaffen für die hohen
inflationskarten nicht zuletzt durch die
vertragswidrige Politik der IZB
aus diesen resultieren wenn man nun
sieht dass die EU-Beamten diese
Inflationsausgleich automatisch bekommen
und auch die Bürger geldbezieher ab
Januar dieses Jahres dann stelle ich mir
vor dass zukünftig vielleicht auch das
Arbeiten verfolgt also diejenigen die
das ganze finanzieren auch per Gesetz
einen automatischen Inflationsausgleich
bekommen und das Argument das dafür gibt
es nicht gelten lassen die Frage ist
angekommen wir können sie sehr schlecht
verstehen die Leitung ist nicht gut aber
ich habe verstanden dass es ihnen um
automatischen Inflationsausgleich geht
gesetzlich geregelt sind
ich halt davon relativ wenig weil
da schwebt immer eine Gefahr drin
nämlich dass man sozusagen so eine Art
galoppierende Inflation auslöst also
dann wenn man immer aus das hat auch in
südamerikanischen Ländern gegeben aber
immer die Inflation ausgleicht dann
setzt man kann man nämlich so eine Lohn
Preisspirale in Bewegung setzen das kann
extrem gefährlich werden also deshalb
hat eben gesagt das war eine Krücke
dabei bleibe ich auch also das ist diese
einmalige Situation die durch den
Ukraine Krieg ausgelöst wurde und ich
finde dabei soll es bleiben also wir
haben ja dieses funktionierende System
in Deutschland wir streiten relativ
wenig wir finden dann doch immer wieder
von halbwegs vernünftige Lösungen also
das ist eingeübt das funktioniert und
aber das ist das Reich sozusagen danke
in Hövelhof ist Rita Meyer am Telefon
Frau Meier guten Tag ja guten Tag
damit der Ausgleich einigermaßen laufen
könnte frage ich mich warum muss ein
Arzt mehr verdienen wie eine
Krankenschwester die arbeitet dem Arzt
zu im Krankenhaus durch ihre
Aufmerksamkeit
wird schließlich einiges mit Sicherheit
verhindert
hinzukommt
auch die besuchen Universitäten Schulen
wie die Krankenschwestern oder auch
andere warum muss der Ausgleich so hoch
sein die Verdienstmöglichkeiten dass das
kann doch nicht sein wir könnten viel
mehr Ausgleich haben in den berufen wenn
das bisschen mehr Gerechtigkeit bricht
ist ganz spannend Frau Meier ich meine
sie haben es jetzt zugespitzt
tatsächlich haben wir im öffentlichen
Dienst ja recht geringe Unterschiede
zwischen qualifizierten und weniger
qualifizierten Berufen und der
Tarifabschluss schiebt das jetzt auch
weiter zusammen aber es ist natürlich
nicht so extrem dass Ärzte und
Krankenschwester wenn man das gleiche
verdienen im Krankenhaus Frau Krüger es
ist in der Tat so dass es noch eine
relativ große Spreizung gibt zwischen
zwischen den Beschäftigten was das
Einkommen angeht relativ rein verglichen
mit der Wirtschaft also Kennzeichen des
öffentlichen Dienstes ist dass die
Spreizungen relativ klein ist ja aber es
gibt natürlich schon eine große es gibt
eine Spreizung und man muss sagen dass
eben diese Socke Beträge ja auch ein
Versuch sind die Spreizung zu verringern
und das ist ein richtiger Entwicklung
und das ist etwas was die Gewerkschaften
noch gar nicht so lange machen denn
früher gab es einfach nur prozentuale
Erhöhungen und das bedeutet eben dass
die die viel verdienen noch viel viel
mehr verdienen und die anderen eben nur
ein bisschen mehr verdienen und ich
finde es eine richtige Entwicklung diese
Spreizung tatsächlich zusammenzubringen
okay vielen Dank bin sicher auch das
sehen nicht alle am Tisch so aber von
Maja ich finde es spannend auf was für
Punkte der hier noch kommen ist ein
riesen Thema Gruß nach Hövelhof das ist
in Ostwestfalen Lippe ja Tschüss
dann vermute ich Friedrich Otto ruft uns
aus Gilserberg in
ist das in Nordhessen gut dass ich
nichts gesagt habe wir konnten
willkommen in der Sendung
wenn besonders verschulten Kommunen ein
Teil der Schulden erlassen wird werden
damit nicht die Kommunen die sparsam
Gewerkschaft haben bestraft ja werden
Kommunen sozusagen
verwöhnt wenn sie schlecht
gewirtschaftet haben bei dieser
Diskussion über den schuldener sie haben
zweimal schon abweichende Meinungen
durch Finger zeigt zu Protokoll gegeben
jetzt sind Sie dran
ein
Anreize das eine ist wer früher gespart
hat wird jetzt ein bisschen bestraft und
man kann sich dann darauf verlassen dann
wird es ja immer so sein und die ganzen
Schulden finanzierten Spaßbäder werden
jetzt halt von der Gemeinschaft der
Steuerzahler übernommen deshalb tun sich
ja auch die Länder so schwer das zu
realisieren und man muss damit irgendwas
vorgehen und auch die Kommunen selber
zur sparen
Gruß nach gilberberg Herr Otto danke
dass Sie dabei sind jetzt hatten bei
Nord- und Südhessen heute kommt auch
nicht oft vor und jetzt sind wir im
Bergischen Land vor den Toren von Köln
bei Michael Müller in Wermelskirchen
guten Tag
ja meine Überlegung ist jetzt in eine
wie soll ich sagen etwas grundsätzliche
Richtung die sich der Tarifstruktur
die Eingruppierung der einzelnen
öffentlich dienstler ist ja wie soll ich
sagen verhältnismäßig stark es werden
wie soll ich sagen seit Jahrzehnten
immer wieder die gleichen Stufen
geschleppt
und
Pflegekräfte und Erzieher und so weiter
haben wir sind in bestimmten Zielgruppen
drin aus dem sie nicht rauskommen und
wir haben dort kaum Möglichkeiten es
müsste meines Erachtens geschehen dass
also die über den Verwaltungen ein wenig
mehr stehen bleiben und die anderen
Gruppen angehoben werden alles aber
nicht finanzieren können alle
gleichmäßig nach oben zu ziehen aber es
müsste eine gründliche
Umorganisation des eingruppierungswesen
sind stattfinden ja das heißt wenn ich
sie richtig verstehe sie sagen man
sollte nicht wie jetzt geschehen gucken
in welcher Tarifgruppe ist jemand
sondern in welchem Arbeitsbereich ist ja
müssten aufgefächert werden und die
entsprechenden Arbeitsbereiche angehoben
werden bei denen des attraktiv ist Leute
zu beschäftigen und die anderen bei den
anderen Ebene zu sagen ihr seid hier gut
beschäftigt und seit Jahren mit einem
sicheren Arbeitsplatz versehen das muss
jetzt erstmal reichen können guter
Gedanke danke schön oder kluge also nein
spannender Gedanke ich will es nicht
bewerten ich finde den Club erwähnchen
also die Idee ist sehr gut und ich finde
auch da muss man darüber nachdenken aber
ich finde sogar eine viel größere
Liberalisierung oder oder
Liberalisierung der Lohngruppen
beziehungsweise die könnten eine höhere
Eigenständigkeit der Kommunen was die
Lohnfindung angeht und auch von Land und
Bund finde ich viel besser aber dann
kriegen wir wirklich dann besteht die
große Gefahr von Verwerfungen also dann
dann können Kommunen wie Frankfurt die
sich unter anderem leisten 60 Museen zu
unterhalten die können aus ganz
Deutschland die Leute holen und abziehen
also dann müssen wir auch andere
Finanzierungswege für die Kommunen
finden was natürlich auch sehr
kompliziert werden kann Herr Müller
danke für Ihren Impuls Gruß nach
Wermelskirchen und wir haben heute
hessenschau hier Bernd Fleischmann in
Fulda hallo Herr Fleischmann schönen
guten Tag Fleischmann aus Fulda ja mich
würde interessieren ich bin Zugbegleiter
bei der Deutschen Bahn was denn die
Runde denkt wie das bei der Deutschen
Bahn weitergeht und ob dieser
Tarifabschluss vom öffentlichen Dienst
übernommen werden wird
ich habe eben schon wer hat das ja jetzt
melden sich alle haglücken ich glaube
sie hatten schon was dazu gesagt genau
also die es ist so dass natürlich eine
Gewerkschaft wie die Bahngewerkschaft
die EVG auf keinen Fall sagen kann dass
sie den terminabschluss öffentlichen
Dienstes übernimmt weil dann bräuchtet
man sie ja nicht wofür Mitglied bei der
EVG sein also das heißt ähm das ist
jetzt mal so eine Frage wie sich eine
Gewerkschaft postiert allerdings finde
ich jetzt für die Mitarbeiter der Bahn
das ganz ermutigen dass die Bahn gesagt
hat das Volumen kann sie sich vorstellen
weil das ist ja relativ viel was da im
öffentlichen Dienst jetzt bei der
Schlichtung angeboten wird das heißt es
ist schon mal ein Schritt für eine
Einigung jetzt wissen wir auch die EVG
hat mehr gefordert als im öffentlichen
Dienst sogar gefordert wird und es war
natürlich so dass die EVG in den
corona-jahren wo ja irgendwie keine Züge
gefunden und die Bahn wahnsinnige
Verluste hatte sich sehr zurückgehalten
hat bei den Lohnerhöhung also ich glaube
es wird am Ende mehr aber auskommen als
er dem Schlichtungsvorschlag für den
öffentlichen Dienst aber natürlich wird
das verhandelt werden weil die
Gewerkschaft muss ja auch zeigen dass
man sie braucht und sie kennen ja auch
das Thema mit der Konkurrenz
Gewerkschaft der Lokführer die jetzt
überall versucht bei der EVG die
Mitglieder abzuwerden allein schon
deswegen werden wir glaube ich auch am
Dienstag noch keine Einigung sehen Herr
Fleischmann die presseclub-redaktion
keine Verantwortung falls der hageluten
sich irren sollte also das war eine
Meinung und keine Vorhersage aber die
Zeitung auch nicht
wollen Sie Ihre Meinung dazu mit uns
teilen wenn Sie selbst Zugbegleiter sind
ja also bei uns in der Belegschaft ist
die Stimmung schon sehr kritisch nachdem
natürlich auch die 14% Lohnerhöhung bzw
Boni Erhöhung des Vorstandes
durchgeführt sind und
ein Zugbegleiter verdient ungefähr 2000
€ netto das mit Nachtschicht
Wochenenddienst Übernachtungen und ja da
wird Zeit und der Großteil von uns
findet die Forderung der EVG bei weitem
nicht erhöht und wir hoffen dann halt
auch wenn die EVG sich nicht durchsetzt
auf die GDL im Herbst muss man schon so
klipp und klar Lokomotivführer
Gewerkschaft die immer ein bisschen
radikaler unterwegs war genau und die
haben bewiesen sie können hart bleiben
das sind wir so von der EVG bisher noch
nicht so gewohnt muss man sagen ja
vielen herzlichen Dank für den Einblick
Herr Fleischmann Dankeschön finde ich
passt zu dem Thema was du gerade im
Anruf vorher hatten dass man doch sehr
genau im Berufsgruppen reingucken muss
und es wirklich immer schwerer wird so
über alles eine Meinung dazu zu haben
oder eine faire Lösung zu finden vielen
Dank auch bei Ihnen zu Hause im Netz
fürs Mitmachen und ja genießen Sie den
Rest des Sonntags groß aus Köln und
lassen sich gut gehen
[Musik]
der älteste Nationalpark der Welt
die raue Natur in den Rocky Mountains
ist eine Herausforderung für die Tiere
die im Park leben ihr Überleben hängt
von den Kräften der Natur ab der Wandel
der Jahreszeiten im Yellowstone
Nationalpark zwei Folgen morgen 20:15
Uhr bei Phoenix
weil Demokratie eben keine elitäre
Angelegenheit ist sondern alle
gleichermaßen dazugehören damit niemand
ohne Stimme bleibt weil Diktatoren und
Tyrannen Populisten und Verschwörer
keine Alternative sind
damit wir unser Leben gemeinsam
verwirklichen gestalten und verteidigen
muss Demokratie jeden Tag aufs Neue
belegt werden mehr Demokratie wagen
mitmachen mitreden mitdenken damit
Demokratie nicht nur Theorie und Idee
bleibt reichlich Anregung liefern die
Dokumentationen bei Phoenix auch online
und in den Mediatheken von ARD und ZDF
Winteroffensive Frühjahrsoffensive seit
Wochen wird mit diesem Begriffen über
eine mögliche Wende im Krieg gegen die
Ukraine gesprochen die Kämpfe im Osten
des Landes gehen weiter der Westen hat
Raketenabwehrsysteme geliefert Polen
gekampfjets schicken kann die Ukraine
die russischen Truppen zurückdrängen
Zweifel daran wurden durch
veröffentlichte amerikanische
Geheimdienst Dokumente genährt der
Konflikt mitten in Europa hat längst
einen globale Dimension in dem vor allem
die USA und China ihren Machtkampf
Proben ein verhandlungsfrieden ist nicht
in sich so auch Annalena Bär Bock die
bundesaußenministerin heute im Bundestag
Putin gegen die Ukraine droht ein
langjähriger Krieg unser Thema heute in
der phönix-runde
[Musik]
als ich das letzte Mal hier bei der
regierungsbefragung war war das kurz
nach dem brutalen russischen Angriff